School everything I've seen with you
seemed really humble and that tells me
you have a solid foundation tell me
about your upbringing I come from a huge
family you know six siblings so all
seven of us my parents great people as
well from Marietta Georgia my family is
a basketball oriented yeah first
athletic oriented how was it when you
had to have that conversation with your
parents about because everybody went to
college right how was that conversation
like you know what I'm thinking
something different like I'm thinking
about going to g-league route or doing
something totally different than going
to college what was that conversation
like it was an easy conversation
honestly the offer that came to me
unexpectedly I knew I know things are
going to come to me because I was
working hard right when the Julie came
and you know they gave me the
opportunity I haven't really seen myself
going that College route you know I've
always seen myself going pro and they
believed in me and they knew what I was
trying to do and they knew I was what I
was trying to accomplish I think that's
cool to both you guys so like your
parents have laid such a foundation they
can trust you yeah to grow across the
country because they raised you right
and also it's a kudos to your maturity
right when I was 17 I was not that
mature
future star for sure scoot Henderson
he's 19 years old and he has a jump shot
he has the ability to to get into the
passing Lane you can defend he can do it
all all the sacrifice they're close to
Plano
like you're you're very close now what
separates you from the rest of the class
I think it's my mindset and uh my
maturity I think I was ready last year
honestly and I'm glad I did two years
but uh last year just based off how fast
I was able to mature and I just learned
I think that that's what really
separates me and I love taking like
constructive criticism so you love
getting better yeah like I love when
I make a mistake
and I can like learn from it yeah have
you ever seen an atmosphere like this
for a non-nba game I mean you could feel
the electricity their lives I think that
LeBron and mellow played against each
other in high school
I love this
man Henderson he's been the star tonight
so far when I saw you play against
Victor win benyama the thing that stood
out to me
wasn't the quote-unquote matchup it was
the the fire you were playing with I
could see a different fire like you got
that kid Henderson
seeing that it came out like you were
gonna send a message and that was really
impressive Russell Westbrook does that a
lot what have you stole from him every
time I used to watch Russell Westbrook I
always used to see him like a reaction
he's a dog oh my goodness
it no matter who who we going against
it's not something you can really uh
work on yeah you can't work on that you
gotta you don't and I feel like you know
I got that in me too everyone with
infants you League at night feels like
he's the best player he should be the
number one pick rookie year what's your
goals rookie rickettiere
you said that with no hesitation yeah
real kid here yeah I like that I like
that okay what else besides rookie here
I want to be known as like a defensive
player as well like uh somebody I could
do everything on the court this boy I'll
probably watch film with him the most
how he leads and how he uh makes the
right reads at all times yeah and it's
just how he you know how he sees a game
and how he can slow down and uh he can
read the game when he's doing fast as
well it's a weapon right yeah and
especially playing with Chris and you
have a lot of the same qualities you
feel like when you're playing with him
and when you're watching him he's in
control of every single possession
that's how I feel when I'm watching you
what's draft night gonna be like for you
driving is going to be a family night
it's gonna be a night where I'm have
everybody there
but I'm gonna throw like a draft night
party or whatever you gotta have a party
I'm a dumb joke you only get drafted
once you go nowhere I don't know where
the fan how are you guys want to say
that for sure facts it's gonna be a
special night for sure you know just uh
all the hard work from here on out but
uh you know it's just the beginning I
played 20 years in the league
um I did some things individually but
there was nothing like draft night so
make sure while you're there you and
your family are present just make sure
you guys enjoy that moment because you
only go through it once yeah well man
you know what I really am a fan of yours
I actually follow you on Twitter you
didn't see it so I had to unfollow you
because I got to be cool you know I got
to be the OG and be cool but no I
appreciate you I can't wait to to watch
your journey because I really believe
the foundation you have set in the look
you have in your eyes it's not just
about making it for you you want to be
one of the greatest and I respect it
appreciate that for sure no doubt